So this is an amazing exhibit at the
Autry museum
well this exhibit looks at the
photographic collection that was created
by about La Raza magazine and newspaper in
1967 to 1977
This is a pretty seminal
publication that comes out of a
community-based social protest movement
all of these groups are doing something
new as part of their efforts to really
communicate something that's being left
out of the mainstream press
well for the last four or five years the UCLA Chicano
Studies Research Center has been working
with the photographers to develop a
digital archive. Here's a timeline
almost a neural network. Our goal is to really
get this embedded into the educational pipeline.
This is Los Angeles history
it's American history there are 25,000
images so the vast majority of images
that were shot never been seen before
they really went out there with the goal
of showing you things that the LA Times
wasn't going to show you the other
major producer of images was the LA
Sheriff's Department. I love the way they
place new surveillance images.
They documented the people that were
doing surveillance they also took
numerous photographs of undercover
police they took a lot of effort to
photograph youth but you have to realize these
are photographers maybe in their 20s
looking at the generation coming up just
behind them and wanting to capture them
they're also trying to just simply
humanize their community. So I really I
really love this photograph. It brings
together both the role of youth but also
just the immediacy of the press and
they're facing many of the same issues
Do we need another La Raza? The media
environment is changed so much and so
the nature of protest has changed you
see various efforts to kind of pull out
and have portraits. Some of the ones
where they're posing to kind of show the injuries
This kind of implicit trust
between the photographer and the subject
the whole exhibition ends with this kind
of lesson in community
Well and that politics is not
something of individuals identifying in
some abstract terms but of families in a
community